I am my husband's help me.
When I say that statement,
I find there are two ditches to it.
One side finds it demeaning and makes women a second class citizen.
The other portrays women there's nothing more than a cook and a maid.
What's the point of an education
if she's just going to marry and have children?
Both of these have very low views of women.
Being a helper is being in a position of power.
The influence a wife has over her husband is significant.
Being a help me does not meeting an ideal,
perfect wife, but rather fulfilling what the Lord is commanded of wives,
glorifying him in the process.
Whatever that may look like for you.
Remember Proverbs 31 31.
Give her the fruit of her hands,
and let her works praise her in the gates.